HUMID I'LL HAVE AN UPDATE
COMING UP ON 8 NEWS NOW AT 5.
WE'LL SEND IT TO LAS VEGAS.
NOW.
THANK YOU TODAY IS NATIONAL UT IS LAY-OH
LASAGNA DAY AND
WE ARE
CELEBRATING BY SHOWING YOU HOW
TO MAKE A DELICIOUS DISH HERE
TO HELP US OUT IS AND INI THE
OWNER OF PIZZERIA WELCOME TO
STUDIO. THANK YOU'S IS GREAT
TO BE HERE OKAY FIRST OFF WHAT
INGREDIENTS DO WE NEED TO MAKE
THE PERFECT DISH. IT'S A GREAT
LAY OF THEN YOU START WITH
THAT THEN YOU GO WE MAIL.
THAT'S MY MY LITTLE SECRET
BECAUSE OTHER PEOPLE WITH
DIFFERENT INGREDIENTS BUT THE
REAL IS ON YOU HAS MENTIONED
THEN SO THIS IS PRETTY MUCH A
MIX OF FLOUR MILK SALT AND
PEPPER DONE SO MAKE SAID YOU
KNOW LESS HEAVY THEY RECALL
SEE OUT THERE. OK SO THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT GOES INTO REAL
AS I KNEW FROM UNITY. AND THIS
IS THAT THE NEXT LAYER YOU'VE
GOT THE PASTA DOWN SO I DID
LIKE A LITTLE LATER BOTHERED
AND BOSTON AND A LITTLE
OBVIOUSLY PUT PARTISAN
EVERYWHERE. SHE'S IT UP THERE
YOU GO SO MAKING THE START OF
SUMMER HERE TO THE FINISH LINE
IS THE START OF AND TALKING
ABOUT THE INGREDIENTS ARE
FAIRLY EASY TO SEE SO IT
PRETTY MUCH YOU GO YOU KNOW WE
DID LITTLE LAYER OF THE BENCH.
O'MALLEY, YOU
WHEN IT COMES TO THE MEAT
THAT YOU PUT A LASAGNA CAN YOU
CAN YOU GET CREATIVE MAYBE USE
LAMB OR SOMETHING DIFFERENT TO
CREATIVE WITH YOUR MEATS YOU
CAN GET CREATIVE YOU CAN PUT
EVERYTHING YOU WANT HONESTLY,
I MEAN IT DOES IS IT MAKES
WHAT WE DO I LOVE THE NAME WE
DO A MIX OF DIFFERENT MEATS SO
PRETTY IT'S A PORK.
AND THE DEAL. BUT YOU KNOW
YOU CAN EVERY SO TO ME IT WAS
ALL RIGHT AND IT WAS THOUGHT
THAT SAUSAGES IF YOU LIKE A
MIX IT UP THIS IS GOING TO
ADDITIONAL ME JUST THINGS UP
AND GET INTO CRAZY. YEAH,
OKAY, WHICH IS WE PUT IT ON
YOUR SO DISMAL LET NOW ALSO
MAKING LASAGNA THE PASTA THE
LAYER POSTURES WHEN YOU'RE
BORN IN THAT CITY PUT SALT IN
THAT WATER AS YEAH THAT'S THE
KEY ALWAYS DON'T EVER MAKE IT
POSSIBLE SOLD TO BECAUSE
YOU'RE WASTING YOUR TIME
THAT'S A GUARANTEE ALWAYS PUTS
ON OLD DAYS AND DON'T BE
CHEAP.
LOAD UP ON THE SECOND LAYER
OF A OR A THE CITY RIGHT HERE
NICE THEN YOU GO A LITTLE
PARMESAN BECAUSE AGAIN WE PUT
ON NICE COMMUNITY. SO YOU PUT
OUT OF QUESTION TOO WHEN IT
COMES TO THE DISHES LIKE A
WE'RE USING MATTER HOW BIG OF
A DISH, YOU YOU CAN GO TO
PENNSYLVANIA AS YOU WANT OKAY
AT ALL IF YOU WANT TO IDEAS
YOU OBESITY MADE THE BIGGER
ONE, BUT YOU KNOW THIS ONE
USUALLY IT'S 4 TO 5, YOU KNOW
IT'S A GOOD SOAKING WITH THAT
THING IS LAYER REPEAT LARRY
WE GET THIS THIS IS THE
FINISHED PRODUCT, CORRECT TELL
ME THERE'S LOOKS LIKE TO DEFER
LASAGNA IS WHAT ARE WE LOOKING
ONE, SO YOU KNOW WE USE THAT
DEFENSE WHAT IS IN SO IT'S OK
TO SOME DATA SEEN ON ME BUT
THE IMPACT FOR WHATEVER YOU
WANT TO KNOW YOU JUST PUT IT
THERE ARE THAT IS THIS GUY
HERE WHEN IT'S FINISHED
FANTASTIC A PIZZA AS WELL YOU
BROUGHT AT SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE KNOWN IN SAN DIEGO FOR
YOU KNOW A NEW YORK STYLE
PIZZA THAT SPINACH RICOTTA
CHEESE
GUESS KNOW THAT'S AND AND